For years, Star Wars fans have dreamed of
seeing some of the saga's many canceled projects,
from the Underworld TV series to George Lucas'
sequel trilogy.
Would they be just as excited for a droid
spin-off or an Ewok video game, though?
We'll let you decide...
James Mangold's Boba Fett movie could be the
greatest loss the Star Wars fandom will ever
suffer.
The celebrated director and Academy Award-nominated
writer was the man who delivered the superb
final chapter in Wolverine's cinematic story
with Logan — and there can be no doubt that
he would have brought a fantastic Boba Fett
story to the screen.
Mangold proved with both Logan and 3:10 to
Yuma that he can make modern westerns with
equal parts brutal action and thematic heft.
While The Mandalorian has certainly offered
fans a more western-inspired taste of the
Star Wars universe, a feature would have allowed
Mangold to flesh out a more epic story.
This movie might even have been the film that
brought the franchise back into the best screenplay
category at the Oscars, given Mangold's previous
historic nomination for Logan.
Of course, there's no way to know for sure
— but that doesn't make this particular
loss any less painful.
A Wookiee-focused movie was an idea that George
Lucas came up with when initially developing
Star Wars; somewhat disastrously, this idea
eventually led to the Star Wars Holiday Special.
"Whip whip stir, stir, whip, stir, whip whip
whip stir waaaaah!"
But with the right script and a creative director,
this could be something far superior to that
particular outing.
Lucas' original idea was a film that didn't
focus on Chewbacca, but instead allowed for
a more ethnographic study of Wookiees.
No one knows exactly what the story would
have been, but the Wookiee homeworld of Kashyyyk
[has a significant history of occupations
and uprisings that would lend itself perfectly
to a Wookiee-focused story.
The movie would likely dive into their culture
while also offering the classic "rebels vs.
oppressors" storyline that's such a staple
of the Star Wars saga.
And based on the battle on Kashyyyk in Revenge
of the Sith, it probably would have looked
great too.
Of course, you've got to consider the fact
that Wookiees only speak in unintelligible
growls.
While this may seem like a problem, it's also
an opportunity for something really exciting
and somewhat avant garde.
A lack of spoken dialogue has driven some
fascinating movies, such as 2014's The Tribe,
in which the character's only speak in Ukrainian
sign language.
Doing something similar with the Wookiees
could have been a huge success or a terrible
failure… but it would have been fascinating
either way.
A droid-only movie was another concept for
a one-off film that Lucas had in the '70s
— one that also could have developed into
something truly special for the franchise.
The obvious reference point for this kind
of thing is Wall-E, which proved that you
can tell a story that focused on robots and
still be engaging and emotionally impactful.
The major differences, of course, are that
Lucas envisioned a movie with no human characters
at all, as well as the fact that many droids
can speak in languages that viewers can understand.
While the film would not have made room for
any human characters, it would have allowed
for comprehensible dialogue between the droids.
Like the Wookiee-focused movie, the idea here
was not to extend the stories of droids that
viewers knew already, but to tell an entirely
separate story that explored how droids interact
with one another when other lifeforms aren't
around.
Considering audiences have only been given
glimpses of this kind of thing in existing
films, it's likely that many fans would have
clamored at the chance to see a little more.
Star Wars: Underworld was a live action TV
series that was going to take fans into the
murky depths of the Star Wars universe.
The show promised to be a more adult take
on the saga, offering up fresh and exciting
stories that weren't solely focused on the
Skywalker clan.
It would have taken place between the end
of Revenge of the Sith and the beginning of
A New Hope and explored the dark underbelly
of Coruscant.
"You wanna buy some death sticks?"
"You don't want to sell me death sticks."
"I don't want to sell you death sticks."
"You want to go home and rethink your life."
"I want to go home and rethink my life."
The idea this time, however, was to offer
something much more morally ambiguous and
narratively complex than the films themselves.
The small screen format and long form structure
of television storytelling would have allowed
for more dialogue and character driven stories.
The creators' ambitions for the show were
impressive, too, with frequent Lucas collaborator
Rick McCallum telling SFX Magazine:
"The shows we aspire to are The Sopranos,
The Wire, Battlestar Galactica, Deadwood,
all of that group."
While Disney has now moved Star Wars into
the world of prestige TV with The Mandalorian,
that show still feels pretty PG when compared
with the shows McCallum mentioned.
For now, we can hope that the fact that The
Mandalorian's runaway success might be a source
of hope for Underworld's future.
George Lucas' sequel trilogy would have been
very different from the one Disney ended up
producing.
As revealed by Lucas in interviews for the
book The Star Wars Archives, arguably the
most exciting aspect of his trilogy ideas
were the villains.
Lucas' big bads would have been Darth Maul
and his new apprentice, the Twi'lekDarth Talon.
In these movies, Maul's power would not have
been governmental, but instead criminal.
Lucas envisioned a power vacuum after the
fall of the Empire that would have been filled
by Maul, who would have united the criminal
world and become "the godfather of crime in
the universe."
The films also would have placed Leia at the
heart of the story, working to combat Maul's
influence in the galaxy and rebuild the Republic.
Meanwhile, Luke would have been attempting
to rebuild the Jedi Order from the remaining
Jedi who survived Order 66, finding him on
a mission to locate potential Jedi throughout
the galaxy.
The saga would then reveal that it's actually
Leia who is "the chosen one," as she is the
one who brings harmony to the galaxy through
the creation of a true republic.
It's almost certain we'll never get to see
these stories play out now that we already
have a sequel trilogy, but with DC and the
MCU both opening multiverses, what's to stop
Star Wars from joining the fun?
Thanks to the announcement that Lucasfilm
Games are remaking the 2003 classic RPG Knights
of the Old Republic, there have been rumors
abound regarding the long-lost Knights of
the Old Republic III.
Sadly, nothing is yet concrete, and there's
no way to know what the game might look like,
given that it's been more than 15 years since
the last installment.
But according to Chris Avellone, lead designer
and writer on Knights of the Old Republic
II, there was always an idea for a third game.
According to him, the story would have focused
on an ancient and even more evil group of
Sith.
Of course, this won't come as a surprise to
fans of the Old Republic games, considering
the second installment teases a hidden cabal
of "True Sith" on more than one occasion.
Certainly, one of the most exciting aspects
of the third game would be unraveling the
mysteries of these hugely powerful beings,
each of whom was to be given a unique origin
story.
Sadly, no one can be sure whether these ideas
will be a part of Knights of the Old Republic
III even if it does one day appear, but that
won't stop fans from dreaming.
Star Wars 1313 seems like it would have been
the video game equivalent of Underworld, with
the game even apparently aiming for an M rating.
Players would have controlled Boba Fett as
he traversed the 1313th level of Coruscant
and unraveled a massive conspiracy.
Like Underworld, the game would have been
more adult-oriented by virtue of its brutal
violence — as well as a more complex, character-oriented
story.
Like the canceled Boba Fett movie, the game
would also have been the first in its medium
to focus solely on the legendary bounty hunter,
as opposed to the many games in which he takes
a more sidelined role.
But unlike the movie, which many thought would
be more of a western story, 1313 was to be
an urban crime story, something resembling
film noir and mafia stories more than any
western.
At this point, however, it seems that nobody
will ever see this game in any form, which
is certainly a real loss to the franchise.
An animated comedy developed by the creators
of Robot Chicken, Star Wars: Detours actually
has 39 completed episodes.
Apparently, though, it didn't quite fit with
what Disney had in mind for the franchise
when they bought it.
That might seem surprising, given the huge
success of the Star Wars Robot Chicken sketches
among fans.
Clearly George Lucas was willing to let people
make jokes about his beloved franchise, and
the fans would have loved it too, considering
the trailer makes it clear that the show is
stuffed with all kinds of references, easter
eggs, and clever jokes.
"Are not!"
"Are too!"
"Nobody's talking to you, trash can."
It also seems as though Detours would have
been a great way to give more screen time
to characters who only appear briefly in the
movies — such as Dexter Jettster, who, based
on the trailer, seems to have been a main
character on the show.
While co-creator Seth Green has said that
there "isn't an interest" in releasing the
show anymore, fans can still hope that Detours
will eventually see the light of day.
Do it for Dexter, Disney.
Star Wars: Return of the Jedi – Ewok Adventure
was one of two video games developed for release
alongside Return of the Jedi.
For some reason, though, only its sibling,
Death Star Battle, ever made its way to Ataris.
Of course, Ewok Adventure wouldn't be developed
for the Atari today, but the idea of playing
an entire game as an Ewok is undeniably appealing
— whether the concept is retooled for something
grander or stays as little more than a mobile
game.
For example, it's pretty easy to imagine this
concept being retooled into something like
Little Big Planet, giving players the tools
to create maps that include a variety of traps
and contraptions like those the Ewoks create
in Return of the Jedi.
This could also bring a community aspect to
the game that would allow players to share
their creations and fight together against
the invading Empire.
Alternatively, it's very easy to imagine that
the original game would be given a fresher
look while remaining little more than a time-sink
mobile game.
Either way, everyone loves Ewoks, and a video
game centering Endor's vicious little teddy
bears would surely put smiles on a lot of
faces.
Battle of the Sith Lords was a Star Wars video
game that would have allowed players to take
on the role of a young Darth Maul as he grows
into a more powerful Sith Lord — albeit
not entirely of his own volition.
In fact, the game would have delved into how
traumatizing the training of a young Sith
Lord can be, with Maul being kidnapped by
Palpatine as a child and tortured into taking
on the role of his apprentice.
Sadly, the development of the game ran into
timeline and lore issues with the franchise's
plans to bring Maul back as a significant
character in the Clone Wars animated TV show.
Once that happened, the game development team
was left with too little information to work
from while also being locked into new canonical
facts about Maul's life.
Eventually, after significant development
and a number of shifts in the game's trajectory,
the game was canceled.
This isn't only a shame because the game would
have further developed the story of a beloved
character, though that is also true.
But it's also a loss because Battle of the
Sith Lords could have been one of the franchise's
most significant moves into the realm of horror
— with a key aspect of the game being the
way that Maul used his own fear to manipulate
the fears of others.
Sounds pretty cool, don't you think?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.